se cumplen seis años de la desaparición
de los 43 normalistas de ayotzinapa
guerrero y los padres de los estudiantes
aún tienen confianza en el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador de con el
paradero de sus hijos y descubra lo que
verdaderamente ocurrió aquella noche y
en iguala y no esa verdad histórica del
sexenio de peña nieto que aseguraba que
todos fueron calcinados que es hallarse
descartada en esta administración y de
hecho el hallazgo más reciente fue en
julio pasado cuando la universidad de
innsbruck en austria identificó los
restos óseos de cristian rodríguez de
lumbre uno de los 43 jóvenes virus
rosales el abogado de los familiares ha
dicho que próximamente se hará otro
envío de nuestros socios para su estudio
genético el avance más reciente en la
investigación es la vinculación a
proceso el pasado jueves de josé ángel
casarrubias alias el mochomo
presuntamente pieza clave en la
investigación
hay mucha indignación todavía entre los
padres de los estudiantes de hecho la
víspera de este sexto aniversario han
realizado manifestaciones y protestas
tanto en guerrero como aquí en la ciudad
de mexico en la suprema corte de
justicia en la fiscalía general de la
república y el consejo de la judicatura
este sábado el presidente de lópez
obrador dará un mensaje sobre los
avances en la investigación hasta el
momento